чотири дні тому Юлія ще жила в страху
тепер вона може спокійно поснідати зі
своїми дітьми в цьому жіночому притулку
під Києвом
[музика]
вся сім'яках я побита вся в синцях у
мене і тут бачите все синє він мене
вдарив її чоловік каже Юлія завжди
поводив себе нестримано та агресивно але
стосунки у родині погіршилися коли
росіяни окупували південну херсонщину де
жила родина і закриттям заводів чоловік
Втратив роботу і витрачав накопичені
гроші на купівлю алкоголю коли жінка
скаржилася що їй не вистачає коштів щоб
прогодувати п'ятьох дітей Він бив її
моєму синові 15 років Він сказав Мамо
чого ти чекаєш Ти чекаєш поки він тебе
уб'є чи нас просто я отримую велику
підтримку від сина
одного разу Він бив мене на очах у сина
дочка донька кричить маму вбивають
напевно я мало раніше задуматися чи
варто жити з ним
я просто не знала куди І що буду сама
робити з дітьми
зареєстровані випадки домашнього
насильства на початку повномасштабного
вторгнення Росії зменшилися адже
мільйони людей залишили свої домівки або
просто вважали що повідомляти про це не
на часі цього року багато родин
повернулися додому або знайшли новий дім
і кількість випадків зросла згідно з
даними поліції на сьогодні
цих випадків стає більше це пов'язано з
різними факторами зокрема люди були
змушені проживати там з родичами з якими
раніше не проживали або коли був плекаут
і батьки і діти і інші члени родини
знаходилися всі в одному приміщенні
відповідно ситуація домашнього
насильства вона відбувалася частіше і
прояви домашнього
насильствах війна не поставила на паузу
домашнє насильство за інформацією
громадської організації La Strada
Україна за 2022 рік на їхню гарячу
адресу не дійшло понад 38 тисяч звернень
статистика за 2023 рік має бути ще
більшою лише за півроку 19 тисяч заявок
багато проблем лише посилилися зокрема
що стосується родин які втратили своє
житло через війну так внутрішньо
переміщення особи дуже часто можуть
просто не знати куди звертатися на
сьогоднішній день У нас немає
розмежування
це внутрішня переміщена особа ця людина
яка повернулась з-за кордону чи людина
яка знаходилась на території України
алгоритм абсолютно одинаковий для всіх
тому якщо ви є внутрішньо переміщеною
особою ви можете і маєте право первинну
чергу звернутися до поліції за номером
102 ви можете звернутися якщо це
сільська місцевість до старости або
голови територіальної громади якщо це
місто це може бути
представник міської ради Це може бути
безпосередньо центр соціальних служб для
сім'ї дітей та молоді так само це може
бути поліція за номером 102 Ну і
додатково хотіла б наголосити про те що
є гаряча лінія які регулюються на рівні
держави які регулюються громадським
сектором це гаряча лінія громадської
організації глаз правда Україна яка
функціонує за номером 116-123 це також
Урядовий урядова гаряча лінія з
попередження домашнього насильства яка
працює за номером 1547 продовжують свою
роботу і правоохоронні органи Ірина
шурхно очолює новостворений підрозділ у
генпрокуратурі він присвячений
розслідуванню випадків домашнього
насильства за її словами сплеск
кількості внутрішніх справ пов'язаний із
війною повернення військового полонених
осіб цивільних осіб з полону змінюються
у них формат спілкування в сім'ї це і
дуже тяжке матеріальне фінансове
становище переселенців вимушених
переселенців це також безробіття все це
є чинником підвищення випадків
збільшення випадків домашнього
насильства які вчиняються в сім'ї
військовослужбовці чи цивільні особи
можуть страждати від депресій
посттравматичних стресових розладів та
інших емоційних і психологічних трав і у
разі не отримання ними вчасною
психологічної допомоги це може значно
погіршити ситуацію з домашнім
насильством в Україні комплексі так воно
підвищує ризики але чи воно підвищує
ризики тільки там до прикладу домашнього
насильства не обов'язково Тому що вона
може підвищити ризики до вживання там
психоактивних речовин або алкоголізації
тобто в який напрямок та підвищення піде
Ну типу ми не знаємо перебуваючи у
притулку Юлія зрозуміла війна зробила її
чоловіка ще більш жорстоким ніж раніше
якби Росія не вторглася нічого б цього
не сталося ми жили в собі все було б
добре і робота була б
для жінок які намагаються допомогти Юлії
стати на ноги війна Не має значення їхня
увага зосереджена на ній
багато викликів полягає саме в тому що
багато жінок потрібно змусити навчитися
себе любити Їх потрібно навчити себе
любити такою яка вона є приймати себе
такою є багато жінок себе не люблять І
чи навіть через це вони стикаються з
такими відносинами
а поки Юлія займається пошуком роботи
жінка каже що Вирішила більше ніколи не
залежати відкривника щоб годувати своїх
дітей
[музика]